tbs has always done their best
to keep andy and i very happy here doing
the show
and uh they're very sweet and they're
always very thoughtful about ways to
make us happy
recently i couldn't believe this they
went a step further
by providing andy and i with in-show
waiter service
yeah which yeah i mean normally on any
other show we've worked on you
like everyone else you walk to the
cafeteria and you get the
rice pudding tapioca your favorite they
gave us yes these incredible menus we
can order anything we want off these
tbs let's eat now you want to eat now
you have sure
this might as well yeah we have an
in-show waiter
yeah an inch a waiter named craig craig
could you come out here for a second
give it up for craig
hey guys hi there hey how are you good
what can i get for you guys this evening
i want you to go go right ahead andy
okay you know what i'm gonna start with
a tom collins uh
once you use a hayman's reserved gin in
that and use pellegrino
instead of seltzer and instead of simple
syrup can use just a little bit of agave
nectar instead
sure okay yep wow you got that yeah yeah
how about a drink for you conan
uh just pellegrino with lime for me okay
all right and uh what about appetizers
you guys want to start off with
something or
well you're probably gonna write this
down i mean i already got the
that's all right i don't need to that's
fine
all right um i want to start with the
crusted wild
albacore with the pear miso and pickled
radish but you know what if you don't
mind
leave out the red chili go light on the
kumquat confit
maybe just a touch on the side can you
do that a little bit yeah okay
and uh conan oh do you want to split the
the shredded beef yes
absolutely yeah with the farm spring
vegetables yeah yeah yeah
okay i see that's an entree could we
split the shredded beef but have mine as
a partial entree
right right yeah and mine is an
appetizer
yeah okay okay now could i get this
before you bring out the wild album or
the tuna yourself before yeah yeah
this is you should write this no you me
too it's fine it's fine i really don't
a good waiter doesn't have to okay so do
you want anything else to start any
other small plates
uh yeah an additional small plate can i
get the roasted golden beets with the
organic tangerine encrusted pistachio
but if you came with twice the amount of
watercress half the amount of greek
yogurt
half a week got it okay and main entrees
how about main entrees
you should really write this yeah no i
mean i know it's
it's really pile but it's still fresh in
my head so if you just keep going i'll
uh all right well um i'll take the
roasted duck with the fermented black
bean
juice uh the smoked onion and grilled
kailan but i'd like to have
the creamed broccoli come out when i'm
halfway done with the duck
so it's not with the duck it's just a
little later could you okay
i'd be more if you just get a pen i
guess i don't need one though just go
ahead all right wow okay
i'll have the columbia river salmon with
water chestnuts horseradish pecorino
mashed potatoes and white asparagus
and do you have palm hearts we do okay i
do not want any of those
all right on second thought i will have
a cocktail can i have a
lemon gingerini do you know what that is
sure would you just tell me how to make
it
okay it's a little complicated okay all
right uh lemon gingerini first
you grate a three-quarter inch chunk of
ginger and squeeze the juice from that
into the drink with a tablespoon of
sugar
then you add 0.75 exactly ounces of
lemon juice
three ounces of hendrick's gin add four
to six ice cubes and stir until cold
be sure to squeeze lemon peel over the
glass before serving it releases oils
that you can really
yeah you know what if you remembered all
that i you're incredible if you
remembered that
i i did and i am i'd feel better if you
repeated it no
wouldn't i i think we would all feel
better you would just repeat it
no no i i would feel better if i got the
order in because you guys look hungry
all right i'll be right back
i gotta say that guy he is incredible
that's amazing oh god i didn't get
any of that this is what i gotta do this
is my only option can i get my blazer
can somebody stab me
big pins maybe you should write it down
you